في معمل الادويه الروسيه هذا والذي ينتج
منذ اكثر من 20 عاما نطاقا واسعا من
الادويه على راسها الانسولين تحدي
اتون الان
زياده الانتاج في ظل تقارير لجنه وزاره
الصحه الروسيه عن وجود قائمه بما يقرب من
100 دواء
في خانه الادويه النادره في الصيدليات
والمستشفيات
على خلفيه الاحداث الاخيره ازداد الطلب
على الادويه في روسيا واختفت بعض الادويه
من الصيدليات طررنا لزياده الانتاج من اجل
تامين السوق الروسيه بالادويه الهامه
لحياه الانسان لان الانسولين هو ماده هامه
لا يستطيع الانسان العيش من دونها
لم تكت هذه الشركه لتتعافى من تداعيات
كورونا وانقطاع الواردات من المواد الخام
حينها حتى بدات تواجه تداعيات العقوبات
التي فرضت على روسيا لتبدا البحث عن بدائل
للموردين للمواد والمعدات الطبيه
بعد فرض العقوبات ولكن خلال فتره قصيره
استطعنا تغيير المصدرين ووجدنا شركاء جددا
من الدول الصديقه والذين يستطيعون تصدير
كل ما يلزمنا من معدات ومواد اوليه
استقلال روسيا عن الادويه المستورده
وزياده انتاج الادويه المحليه هدفان
وضعهما الرئيس الروسي امام الصناعه
الدوائيه في البلاد مع التاكيد على ضروره
زياده انتاج مواد الخام المحليه لتحقيقها
الادويه ذات المجموعه الواسعه التطبيق لم
تختفي من السوق ولم ترتفع اسعارها لكن
الادويه الغاليه ثمني والتي تؤمن استمرار
الحياه في ظل الامراض الثقيله نعم اختفت
شركه اجنبيه من السوق الروسيه وتراجعي
نسبه الواردات من الادويه الى روسيا الى
نحو تسعه بالمئه تبقى التساؤلات لدى
المواطن الروسي حول مدى امكانيه شركات
الادويه المحليه تعويض هذا النقص كاتيا
العربيه موسكو
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات